hello everyone and welcome to today's
live broadcasts cost-effective robust
digital gene expression of profiling of
up to 96 targets in 96 samples for cell
line screening but encounter like set
reagents presented by Chris Mary who is
a senior scientist at Nana's shrink
technologies incorporation I am Marjorie
Torres of laberd's and I'll be your
moderator for today's event we are
delighted to bring you this educational
web seminar presented by lab weeds and
sponsored by nano string technologies
for more information about our sponsor
visit w-w-w a wrinkle in I would like to
remind everyone that this event is
interactive we encourage you to
participate by submitting as many
questions as you want and anytime you
want during the presentation just click
on the ask a question box located on the
far left of your screen and type your
questions into the drop-down box that
appears on the screen
well answer as many of your questions as
we have time for it at the end of the
presentation if you know trouble
cleaning or hearing the presentation
please click on the help desk button
located in the promotional board at the
bottom or center of your screen or use
the ask a question box to let us know
that you're having a problem this
presentation is educational and thus
offers continuing education credits
please click on the continuing education
credits tab located in the top right
corner of the presentation window
involved the process to obtain your
credits please join me in welcoming dr.
Chris Merrick I will now turn the
presentation over to him I'm a senior
scientist and I'm going to talk to you
about one of these new assays I've been
working on for several years now as now
commercial I want to give an overview
administering this new technology and
where we're going with it right now
so many people on the other side may not
know what encounter technology is and
what manage string does so I'm gonna do
a few slides on that first so what is
encounter technology so what we do is
count molecules or specifically RNA and
DNA molecules and we were single
molecule molecule counting company we
can count up to 800 different targets
per sample for one of our assays to that
acceptable sensitivity which is in the
hundreds of molecules it's done this
counting is done through a simple base
pairing hybridization technique so it's
very robust and there no enzymes
necessary so this is gonna be very
different like a qPCR type of assay now
given that further in the talk and this
doesn't mean your digital data so it's
very simple there's a lot of precision
with our data so what you end up getting
are just counts or just numbers from it
for each of your genes of interest so
below I just you know beautiful image of
some of our barcodes that we used to
count I'm just gonna zoom in there even
idea you know the fundamentals of our
technology begin what we do is we count
these little barcodes and this picture
here on the right show in green would be
an RNA target molecule on the Left
there's a little circle which is a
biotin that captures the molecule and on
the right is a reporter with six
different circles that actually count on
and then what aboard zooming in on
here's an actual image of one of these
barcodes an RNA molecule both target or
measured by our instrument and then I'm
gonna get this technology so the
products we have right now the
instruments we sell would actually run
these assays are shown on the left there
this is a research box so we have the
max instruments print which actually
read out these barcodes like I mentioned
which I'll get to in more details the
conceal a custom asset so if you have a
hundred genes of interest you can design
probes and quantify any of those you
like we also sell panels are they so a
lot of blood people didn't research
right now see an immuno Oncology
neurobiology other fields and I'm
looking at bear
Somerset's genes so we sell custom or
already made panels for these
approximately Android different targets
we were working on other different
technologies here there's another
picture of a box that says DSP that's
different instrument I'm not going to
get into too much but my team also works
on these other things in Rd and so on
the left theory of research which I'm
going to focus on mana string also uses
a masses for Diagnostics on the right we
can press Sigma gene signature assay
that we currently have in the diagnostic
world and we have other other parts of
R&D that again not my parts of our new
focus on those sort of assays to
definitely go to our website to look
into more of that and with all of this
we have software to help analyze the
data and we have internal services to
help get your projects off the ground
there so what are the advantages of
using this technology or barcode
counting technology so going from left
to right here it ends up being simple
and fast so I come from my biology
background they don't let me keep the
star back in the day you know you used
to handling a lot of different samples
doing a lot of pipetting steps this ass
ends up being quite simple you missed a
few tubes together or mix with your
sample shown you know basically a
pipette here put a minute tube then you
put them in a thermo cycler overnight
and that's when the actual and the
actual in in solution hybridization
happens and then you basically load that
up on the next day on an instrument with
you know less than 30 minutes hand on
hands-on time and from they get these
precise counts for it ends up being
highly multiplex so again in each two
you can look up date hundred targets of
image at a time and then because of all
this this the data analysis is quite
simple and we already sell stuff sorry
this actually comes free Ben solver
analysis software and so this like our
normal work was actually quite simple
especially if you have purified RNA what
do I want to focus on a little bit
year and introduce this concept of like
we have a very simple workflow
we've multiplex it quite a lot and
actually run anymore then we can run up
to 96 samples at a time per run we're
also making this compatible with cell
lysate so you don't have to go
completely through in RNA purification
procedure to monitor your sample again
since this is a can be completely custom
assay and we're just measuring nucleic
acid so you can centrally look at any
target in the nice one in the middle
here I have humans and that's gonna be
the focus of my talk and him you know
oncology and looking at the shades of
interest but we can design panels or
custom code sets against any species out
there from nematodes to humans so how
does this work so again I showed the
picture the barcode I'm gonna get a
little bit more now and I saw on the
left here at the picture of a capture
probe that's what we call it and on the
left side so we have a bite in molecule
and then we have a little stretch of
nucleic acid that's about 50 base pairs
long that's been a target of interest so
it's complimentary and then on the bark
of the side we have the next 50 bases
that we target then winds up happening
overnight in the tube as those two
complexes come together hybridize with
the nucleic acid and once that happens
overnight basically put it on our
instrument it's gonna purify this
complex on both sides of the pipe inside
and the barcode side it's gonna be put
on an imaging surface or instruments
gonna image those little barcodes count
them and in the end you basically get
your gene name and how many counts that
work for it ends up in digital
information here's a little picture
showing the orchids on their user
doesn't have to look at those actually
shown those because they're beautiful
images and then you just get counts to
cut those for you and since this nucleic
acids you can look at a lot different
things so I'm gonna focus on messenger
rna's right here but we can also look at
long enough long non-coding RNA gene
fusions
we've got micro RNAs a we can look at
DNA so we can look at single nucleotide
variants
copy number
and at the bottom of a real cell protein
assay so we can actually conjugate
probably goes to an antibody and used a
surrogate to measure protein again the
focus of this talk is going to be
messenger rna's so let's quickly review
what hamstring does right now and again
what I've been working on is this Plex
tech technology and work on is an
alternative to keeping our technology
because it's very competitive with qPCR
in terms of throughput number of genes
you look at and ease of use so on the
right here is shown a 96-well plate and
if you aren't familiar with management
technology most of the runs you can do
nana string we live in this moderate
flex place for genes which is about 800
typically and will usually just run 12
samples times those 800 targets to run
and what we've done for plex says
basically we're looking at higher
throughput more samples at a time but
less genes so stepping the hundred genes
to be shrunk that down to about 96 genes
per sample when you can't even go less
than that and in a typical run you'd
have those 96 genes and look at 96
different samples at a time and 96 is a
number most of us are very comfortable
with working with 8 times 12 sample
plates in those grids so the bandages
for this is since it's a hybridization
ends up be an enzyme free which is which
is great so I'm going on the left here
under efficient workflow and going done
these check marks so it some enzyme free
which makes it easier we're working on
these what we're calling my single
protocol so you don't have to purify RNA
to actually measure What's in yourselves
in the end there's pure pipetting steps
because of these are use just the way
that is set up and if you might have
more genes to that say so you can
measure just 12 genes at a time that's
all you want to do if you want to
measure 96 you buy the other goods and
reagents actually do that but in the
exact same so the workflow is then
anymore if you look at more targets
finally there's an ort steps as I
mentioned so there's no enzymes involved
with that and in the end its period
since the datas of digital and it's not
analog but GPCR you
you can see very small full changes and
since everything's happening in one tube
you don't have to split it and
challenges up reactions so so that's
what we've done here I'm not going to
get into the details on the tricks big
play to actually get 96 samples on just
one encounter run I'll save that for a
different conversation but one other
thing we added to this is made this even
more custom than our normal reagents and
this is kind of probably resonate with
qPCR users so what we do so we have a
target sequence here so let's just call
it C III
that we're looking at what we then tune
or what the customer will do is buy a
probe a we call probe a new protein
against the gene of interest to cover
about 50 base pairs on each size of the
target of interest and again these are
designed by our buyer informatics team
you know more than anyone in the world
on in solution hybridization under our
conditions and though design probes are
highly specific to the genes of interest
for you and then what we do is basically
bridge a reporter tag intern universal
capture tag on the other side using
Universal sequences what I don't have to
get to so in the end it it has a field
aligned qpcr where you're bringing in
your probe a piece or your for reverse
oligos to actually measure your gene of
interest but you're actually not doing
it somatic amplification and these are
just gonna hybridize together so what
the workflow looks like I'm slide so
from left to right this is a being not
much hands-on time which I mentioned
about 30 minutes
so usually clock people and I'm just
getting from left to right here so
there's a plate a 96-well plate you can
imagine you'd have all your samples near
96-well plate
are we in there what we do four-plex
says be in tubes on the left you
interests add in these probe a probe's
that you purchased from no go supplier
it goes across the plate from left to
right so those arrows that are color
floor won't get lost right showing that
and then basically you take that put a
cover on it let it hybridize overnight
and a thermal cycler at 67 degrees and
then you come in the next day take the
cover off the 96-well plate pull all the
way down the different columns and
- 12 o strip - and then number four here
on the far raise that you just load and
analyze that you have them in this trip
tubes loaded one of our cartridges or
cards this year alone and then the
Machine counts it for you automatically
since would be the number nine position
which is where most the time goes but
it's actually not hands long time
cities are the simple steps involved and
another thing I'd like to show
especially for a lot London people a lot
of experience with qPCR so I'd like to
show one other difference between us and
QP stars that each of these little wells
we're showing here some zoomin and just
on a 96-well plate you put like States
in their total barefoot purified a RNA
and each of these wells of what you have
in there is actually at your trade but
you also instead of looking at just one
gene per well in here we actually look
at all my new six genes at the same time
so in this little I say well shown here
a one you have your RNA targets coming
out of your life state we have positive
negative controls for our system in
there
how many sixty genes from those 96 will
have a bunch of housekeepers we also
look at in more than one ounce per
typically and then all the other
references you need in there since I've
been a lot of stuff going on and one two
just quite different and again how does
this overcome some of the issues of the
qPCR so I always like to show you slides
on this stuff right here so you always
start with your sample or say your cells
of interest
typically purified RNA make cDNA out of
it
amplify it and then you get your data
from it and throw this stand there by
cutting steps involved which you can
always pause there and there you also
need to do when you go through your cDNA
and your amplifying it you start you
need to ignore its PCR typically so then
involves samples looking for targets and
having several different replicates for
there and here in this animation we're
just showing there are other issues when
you have enzymes in your acetate there
there's always places where things could
go wrong so we highlight that here
and well basically what we're trying to
do with these flex 10 essays in our
encounter out stays cut right through
all those in somatic steps from what and
basically skin to RNA within this big
green arrow I show here just have a
hybridization have been loaded on
instruments simply and then just get the
data from there I select show a few
different reviews and another paper
about qPCR so again highlight issues
sometimes we unfortunately ignore about
the complexity of it so this is actually
a pretty good review about that and you
know basically you can go in and see
their consequences are this one she's
very analytical so this paper here they
went through a lot of previously
published data from oh six to thirteen
and below and basically one of the big
issues is that a lot of users and I did
this back in the day quite a lot like
about ten years ago when I started doing
qpcr is that I would just use a single
reference gene and that was usually 18s
or gap th which maybe not have been
ideal a lot of times I probably didn't
know if that housekeeper was moving
around with my different drug treatments
so I was doing or whatever experiment I
was doing in there so it's it's not
great and this group definitely believes
it's not ideal just have a reference
gene and in general most people use
these really highly Express reference
changed you know actin captain ATS and
very few publications there's a bottom
bullet point right there very few people
actually validate the reference change
they used to say my housekeepers
housekeeper and that is going to work
out for them so that's this and what
this next table shows I kind of break it
down a little bit and how flux I can
kind of how about some of these issues
is to get through a lot of this you do a
lot of technical replicates with you PCR
so with pluck say you don't need isn't
technical or against ever really so I'll
show some data for that about the
r-squared values between replicas but
senses so I highly reproducible we tend
to not detectable right because we do
them in R&D you need to check the system
but when you're actually doing
experiments at the lab they're not
necessary like they are cute PCR the big
one too is the controls we then built
system controls but they've going back
to these housekeeper's so we have room
for you know 96 different genes I like
to use a lot of real state for
housekeeping genes so I put three to six
here I always put in at least five to
six minimum for some of our like larger
encounter assays will up to 12 24 36
housekeepers which makes you feel a lot
better in the end you trust that data a
lot more and then the assay performance
to we don't have any of these enzymatic
type of things happening in our essays
and the target designs who I mentioned
these probate cookies by informatics and
Anna Stern designs these we understand
them very very well they're highly
specific you don't have to worry about
you know designing your energy PCR
primers so that's right through that
assay so one other to do just show just
a little bit of data with what we
actually did when we'd run those assays
so what I'm gonna show here is a set of
96 genes that we used to look at some
colorectal cancer samples so one thing
we would like to do not everybody has a
96 genes left the top of their head
around say I want you to sign these so
on our website we have about 104
different or work on free selected
animals already designed so these should
help you get started and what you want
to do and everything is customizable so
if I'm looking at this lymphocyte
activity panel I'm liking it but I want
to take five things out of five things
in that's totally possible so these are
usually starting point I like to use
this so just to get us started and show
some data so here this is 96 genes 35
housekeeping genes at the bottom we very
haven't redesigned for here
some rap but any species can be
customized for this it's secure but
curated by remember by informatics team
that is very quickly we've been doing
this for years so we turn these over
very fast and again when we design these
we put at least five in here you get
wasting more if you'd like to then we
have some positive and negative controls
in there so this is just a list of genes
then I'm gonna show some colorectal
cancer samples this is one panel that we
use to look at cancer samples we
wouldn't actually just do these panels
and what we did here is we took 44
colorectal cancer samples and we
purified RNA from those so 44 and we
actually did two technical replicas just
so you know we could show the data how
reproducible it was so that ends up
being a different Wells I mean to get to
96 we took eight other wells for
controls that we used their cinnamon we
can fold on new 6-well plate for this
and when it is here on the left here the
formatting is a little different it's
the same I am emphasizing activity and I
just showed then we also ran it on this
myeloid activity panel on the right here
and in the end I just like to show this
I'm not gonna do too deep in like what
actually happened in today what we
actually see what interesting biology
there is what I just want to show is a
lot of data in just one run or actually
just one day so each of these is massive
key mass right here was just one
encounter run so the top axis is samples
one from top to bottom that axis are the
different genes that we actually
measured and the one on the left right
here the IO lymphocyte activity again
different samples come from left to
right there's a ton of data there and
that was just one encounter run and then
the myeloid activity on the right was
another encounter on so a single user so
one of my group members ran this they
can do just do this in a day if they
have all this suit again idea don't
think too much into I don't want to get
to the data right now but just to show a
lot of data it ends up being you know 90
to 60
you get encounter on it's just taken
from this data just to show us some
reproducibility between tech or
advocates wait I took three samples from
here so these are just block IDs it's
how we name the different samples we
have for these chlorophyll cancer
samples and the green ocean of myeloid
activity panel and I'm showing the
correlation between the two so
unfortunately I didn't label my axes
here they went away these are log to
base counts on the left next to zero to
16 those are log base two Council I'm
showing and again highly reproducible
data when you look at the two technical
replicates for these so the next thing I
want to talk about is so that's the Plex
set assay and what we've done here is a
smaller gene says I'm gonna stroke quite
large 96 love genes mister 12 and 96 or
the number of targets we typically look
at what we want to do and we can get
this data pretty quickly with very
little hands-on time one bottleneck at
this point would be if I'm doing a cell
line type assays I don't really want to
purify all my RNA for all those samples
so what I what I want to focus on
through most of this talk is what we're
calling lice and go protocol so how come
you minimize the time of actual sample
handling sample prep to cut that bottom
napkin throw right into our flex at
assay to get paid it even faster so I
think showing this little figure just a
back at that quench they show you this
before but what I'm not doing difference
here is I'm highlighting the lysate and
a little green circle and you know is
there an easy way just to throw down all
yourselves a to 96 well plate throw
something on top of them let them lice
take that sample and put it right into a
hybridization reaction so again we spend
a lot of time on that
so one thing we did we went through our
luggage from lysis buffers to figure out
how to make this possible and again an
arm do spend a lot of time on this and
we looked at a lot
prints all types so I'm gonna go for on
the left all the way down through these
different bullet points so he'll really
pay human trying even amounts to primary
cells suspicious cell lines and
appearance on lines and in the end all
these settings are very different and
behave differently and you have to
license ways so we figured that out even
though they are different you can
usually even put them in just a few a
few buckets all show data for a lot of
these different cell lines yeah this is
why we're very confident that this is
working out probably for all seven lines
I'm son Brent but what's determined for
these unit range of cells and get the
data was really good r-squared values in
the end we you know going to buffers for
these protocols that we developed one is
a buffer logic we're familiar with which
is our LT for pi Jen so you see this in
your hygiene kits all the time if you've
been at all in the lab and basically
what this is well nice tells us our LC
which is con for people but we basically
be digitally dat down since of being a
one-third dilution of our LT that we use
for these life states and the reason we
have to do this is it's a Nana strain
specific phenomenon there's just the
hybridization specific phenomenon where
if you add too much of this cage buffer
which is our LT became basically
interfere with our organization event so
we had to modify that protocol to fit
that to make it work and then we end up
using this for primary cells this works
quite well for a nossa primary cells and
then we use the I script buffer from by
arrive for suspension in here installed
lines the goal of all this which I'm
gonna shows that you know which one
determine the buffers that are necessary
to show complete lysis and make sure it
looks correlated well with purified RNA
that was running parallel from the same
style lines and then we also go through
we're working on identifying
minimal number of cell used a lot of
that depends on the cell line you're
looking at and the gene of interest it's
high or low expresser and then we're
also working
more protocols and when I list here is
optimizing storage protocols that were
working on so you know I just wanna show
some very simple graphs just to get the
start of correlations purified RNA Nats
but what I'm showing here is total cons
on the left so I have 96 genes of
interest which very similar to listed
previously I'm looking at that and just
seeing all the number of counts I'm
getting for my one encounter rod and
then a cell input is on the bottom -
it's a little squashed for the primary
cells graph but you may be let's just
look at the middle graph focus there for
suspension cell lines so when I'm
showing the bottom numbers it tells them
put into well and they're just looking
at the total counts gotta get from that
if I had more styles like spent more
counts and we see this for all these
different cell lines right here so it's
the data and emotion replicates for
those but here to do with multiple times
they replicate really well one
comparison and really like just show is
this one where I actually look at
purified RNA and compare that to what
I'm calling crude like States on the
left and again these are long log base 2
counts I'm sure there's a log base 2
encounter counts
I'm showing so these are the air
suspension salt lines and these were
laced with I sugar buffer and ran with
our protocol that we've developed and we
have a melanoma cell lines t CFC and
turkey on empty too
shown here and again bottom axis is
purified RNA and then crude life states
are on that left axis top down and again
good very high correlations for all
these that gives us confidence that
we're measuring it's very similar if you
were to go through and do the entire RNA
purification next one one a major
interest for a lot of people is your in
pregnant alright so I'm showing on
student PBMCs and stimpy PMC's on top
you can really create a correlation and
you can see the de Grasse just kind of
up a bit because a lot of genes are
being expressed down the stimulated PBMC
condition baby monocytes and key red is
also showing really nice correlations
with purified RNA first our crew fights
aids and finally we've also done this
with nonce primary cells so Mouse bears
dendritic t-rex and spleen also works on
Mouse with a mouse specific probe set so
we went through to a lot of work on this
to dial in the protocols for these tests
a lot of cell lines and in the end we
like diluted rlt for primary cells an
i-strip buffer we believe works best for
a lot of cell lines and this is a list
of some of the cells we've actually
looked at probably so we cover this is
about almost 20 different cell lines
just a survey what's going on and all
the protocols are pretty good for all
these do you think it's gonna work
really well for all different cell lines
out there so we have this light state
protocol you're good about writing about
and I mentioned the multiplexing earlier
so now I just want to combine all these
two together and shift some data for
that so again I'm gonna show this panel
one more time side activity panel that
we did we're actually looking at targets
of interest in immunology right now so
what we did here in the lab is actually
combined the Plex that assay with these
like state assays to get really high and
this is again one big key map but I like
to show here of all the data is that we
actually on the right here make
different cell lines in different cell
types listed primary cells listed on the
right and then these are actually all
these data points are averages for
replicas just to make this heat map at
least somewhat viewable to you guys so
well I'm just on the far left there
annotations with different colors for
different numbers of cells play two
different lysis buffer use different
cell types primary cell lines and what's
the nice series you see all these
different combinations so this just kind
of summarizes everything I've talked
about it works for different internal
cells or four different lysis buffer
different types of cells and you can see
a nice dynamic range of the different
counts here you can see different cell
types of clustering as you'd expect to
the top part five cell lines are
actually here in some lines they look
more similar than the other cell lines
at the bottom the bottom two targets a
C+ donor one donor to those are PMC's or
c+ PBM seized from two different donors
they look most
similar to each other it's compared to
all the other cells being in our lives
so in these are primary cells mention
cells adhere in styles all work get a
nice data out of all of us yeah finally
again just a little teaser of what kind
of data you can actually get from this
all this data makes sense you know when
you dig in deeper deeper into so we did
four replicas but for all these so with
that we can get p-values and look at
full changes between different cell
types in here so on the far left I'm
looking at K cells and you know you
could do instant start this slight a bit
once a section in your hands and you'll
see that again we're seeing the expected
patterns they're just gonna point out
can't see my pointer but on the NK cells
versus T rugs on the left you see grands
lemon greens like the way to the right
expressed in the name k then for the tea
routers I'm seeing my ctla4 Fox p3 and
other targets on the left so those are
higher in the tier X the graph on the
right was just distant PBMCs versus on
student PB and Aziz again you're saying
all their shift and targets as you
stimulate the P BMC's p-value shown here
I drew a line at two so that's a PITA
and it's a native one log base 10 scale
so it ends up being you know a two point
one p-value is highly significant see
changes left and right over there
so you know I heard you look a little
bit closer at that data and when you
grab this PDF so finally so whatever we
want summarizes that so Plex that's like
Segoe
flex said maybe go through the qpcr
today vicious made that gene analysis
part of it much more simple Y Cinco gets
there a lot of our dishes you have with
our next certification all the time and
effort it takes to do that so it'll be
much faster protocol get a lot more date
a lot faster so like they did at your
corley as well was totokira fide our man
which we expect when it's working and
then the data demonstrates ha
high-quality data so again this is this
kind of Caesar data with cells that will
be purchased from different commercial
suppliers we did a few stimulation PBMC
types of experiments to make sure
everything makes sense but now we're
really you're like try this some more
elaborate experimental samples so we
like to reach out to others for that and
work on collaborations and right now
we're actually in the lab now that we've
dialed in these protocols we're
developing these datasets right now with
the really interesting samples and then
at the very bottom of the contact
information for a project manager Anisha
it works on flexuz and again we're
looking at another sample types we have
cell lines dialed in and definitely
contact Anisha if you want to work with
us finally you know solutions can repeat
necessary those cell numbers and high
simple multiplexing very quickly in the
last you know commercial thing we wanted
to show you was for a lot of this since
we want to engage with the community and
get this out there and have people use
this to help but this we'd like to put
out these different grant programs and
then eight years from those pre-selected
pathway panels I should a few here and
this a few slides ago we actually have
many of these designed out on our
website and you can just go to our
website look at these different panels
we we looked at the ideas you stuck on
these panels and you can actually test
your reagents with one of these kits to
run the encounter looks at assays and
then you know you get your free agents
for flex n96
you get to run it and then there's more
information there on how to actually try
that out so yeah thank you for your time
really appreciate it
and hopefully hear from you soon about
using these and studies of thank you
thank you Chris for that informative
presentation we will now start the live
Q&A portion of the webinar if you have a
question you'd like to ask please do so
now
just click on the ask the question
drop-down box located on the far left of
your screen and click the send button
well answer any of your questions as you
have time for let's get started
our first question is what technology
how do you need to optimize target
primers okay so these were Nagas to keep
PCR primers where you have a forward and
reverse primary identification we don't
really optimization at all start by an
informatics team design is named for you
then you order them you don't have to do
the normal sort of other QC checks for
those make sure primers to interact and
would actually enclose the kitchen
efficiency is basically the primers
thank you our next question is what are
the minimum number of genes I can
analyze easier just the way clucks that
works the max is 96 and all the hate I
showed was closer to 96 we first
launched this to 12-inch 24 genes about
is about a year ago when we get that so
we do have different tests to look at
twelve genes 24 48 72 and 96 at a time
and you can look at any number of genes
in between if you want to do less than
12 you can you know sometimes it's hard
to pick 12 genes even of interest if
you're hyper focused on just a few a lot
of times we encourage people with thrown
more housekeepers if you need to do that
winds up being the same amount of work
between 12 and 96 genes
it's just ordering more elegans and then
a company you buy them from well I'm
Alan bought them and
really thing for you in combination
since I mean see my work thank you for
that answer
our next question is if I'm using these
protocols do I need to convert RNA to
DNA so no you do not need to convert so
you know early on I mentioned for our
standard and string technology don't to
convert RNA because hybridize in our DNA
these are interacting with our directly
so you don't need to make from these
with the lingo protocols staying same is
trio any likes them army comes out of
the cell in their solution is liberated
and thank you looks like we have time
for one more question our last question
is this word good tissues different
[Music]
definitely want to consider
collaborations on that but have not
looked into yet that are eager to look
into it and develop those protocols I
would like to once again thank dr. Chris
Merrett for his presentation I would
also like to thank nano string
technologies for making today's
educational webcast possible before we
go I want to let everyone know that
today's webcast will be available for
on-demand viewing through August of 2018
you'll receive an email from labyrinth
letting you know in this webcast will be
available for read by please share that
announcement with your colleagues who
may have missed today's live event
that's all for now thank you for joining
us and we hope to see you again soon
goodbye